hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 1914 tournament
of sankt-petersburg we already finished
the 1914 tournament through kappa
Blancas perspective but we mentioned
that we are going to cover two bonus
videos one you already seen it was last
curse excellent victory in the final
round against Frank James Marshall and
here we have our own names which versus
dr. Zuber tarush the game that was
supposed to be the winner of the
brilliancy prize but then kava Blancas
game over Bernstein won the brilliancy
prize for this tournament but this game
won the second brilliancy prize so I do
hope you enjoy it and a lot of people
say that it it reminds them of the
famous 1889 victory by world champion
Emanuel Lasker against johann bauer
the famous double Bishop sacrifice and I
will put a link to that game in the
description below if you want to check
it out but you know just I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it
so the second bonus video nimzowitsch
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 alas Chris game against power was the
birds opening but yeah you'll see where
the similarity comes from d5 Knight to
f3 we have c5 now the the cross
variation we have c4 and now II 6
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined where Black has this early c5
III Knight to f6 just developing Bishop
d3 white also just normal developing
moves in knight c6 Bishop to d6 by black
and now nimzowitsch castles with Bishop
to d6 now b3 and here also castles by
Tyrus Bishop to b2 Finn Kettering the
dark square Bishop now as you can seen
nemzer which pieces are eyeing the black
King Knight to g5 might be an idea Queen
might come to f3 maybe to h3 a lot of
attacking possibilities here for white
but Tyrus wants to do the same
so he goes b6 he prepares the Bishop to
b7 he also wants to have a very strong
but repair of course Knight B to d2 and
here Bishop the b7 and it's not very
often that you will see quite
symmetrical game like this where both
players will have a
a really strong bishop pair this is very
nice look to see one by names of each
and now Queen to e7 just developing the
queen connecting rooks and white still
has to decide what to do now so here
names of its plan is next he wants to
get his Knight to f5 the e6 pawn is
controlling the f5 scores so first he
captures see captures and d5 and now
after each character's the f5 square is
free for his knight so nice to h4 it
seems like a weird idea but you know
it's efficient Knight to f5 would be an
excellent square also it would come with
an attack on the Queen and the bishop so
here parish has two options he could
either go Bishop to c8 which is not
something you want to do play the bishop
back also you just connected your roof's
you want to get the other rope into the
game as well the other option is g6 this
is the best option so he plays it and
now immediately after g6 is playing him
so it just goes back with the night he
says okay my knight is no longer needed
here now I'm just gonna retreat it and
I've created a weakness so you know a
lot can be learned by this little from
this little maneuver okay Tyrus
continues developing rook a to d8 lining
up the rook with the white queen which
might you know come in handy in the
future D captures on c5 now tower named
Josh also wants to open up his a very
strong dark square bishop be captures on
c4 c5 and now Bishop to b5
now nimzowitsch slight square bishop
seems to be not all that great as white
created this this fianchettoed structure
so he wants to exchange it for for
blacks night and also blacks night is
included in the you know five footer for
the central control a lot more than the
light square bishop but here comes
Knight to e4 and okay Bishop captures
the Bishop captures and now you could
play Knight captures on e4 but after
pawn captures there are ideas of Bishop
captures here the rook is still aligned
with the Queen so we'd have to go back
92 and then Bishop c7 again opens up a
nice attack here it would be just a much
more enjoyable to play this with the
black pieces but okay after Bishop
captures on c6 we have Queen to c2 now
just getting the Queen out of the C file
and also after the knight is exchanged
which it is a Knight captures was played
Knight captures not white has this
option of going Queen to c3 and already
threatened some checkmating ideas but
Tara doesn't wait here
tarush plays d4 and this is the critical
moment of the game where you really have
to realize you know your spidey sense
has to start tingling the the black
Bishop pair is extremely powerful here
so what do you do here there are two
good options here one is to push efore
to simply block the light square bishop
the other one is even better just played
g3 and it seems like cannot move to do
because black has this D captures an e3
now if you capture the Queen captures
with Czech but the point is White has
this Queen c3 move and now White is
threatening checkmate you have to
prevent this it's f6 and now you capture
with the Queen let's see Queen captures
F captures and now you play this end
game where you have a bishop at night
against a bishop pair and also both you
wellokay your opponent has three point
islands you have for porn islands no you
also have three point islands so I mean
it's black is a little bit better
because of the strong bishop pair but it
is playable unfortunately for our names
which he didn't play E 4 or G 3 he
played pawn captures on d4 and now of
course you all know what's coming
especially if you know about last quest
famous game against power Bishop
captures on h2 it's interesting Bishop
captures and g2 also wins simply because
after Bishop captures you cannot save
the rocker you just have to allow black
to capture it or or you have to allow
black to continue with his attack if you
capture the bishop then comes Queen g5
King to h1 and now Queen f4 the bishop
and Queen already sorry already
threatened a very nice shipment here on
h2 the only way to prevent it is nice to
have three this kind of prolongs it
Queen captures with check King g1 and
now just see captures on d4 and whatever
you do I mean this that there's a lot of
ways you can win here with the black
pieces just again threaten checkmate or
you can bring the rook into the game
doesn't really matter but let's say even
if white try something like Queen to c6
they immediately either trade queens are
bringing the Queen
the defense it doesn't help Bishop
captures on h2 a very nice move
King captures and now Rugby five blocks
the trade of queen attempt and whatever
wife plays well rook to h5 followed by
root 2 H 1 will be checkmate
or white will have to give up the Queen
and then it's just a queen and rook
versus two looks and a bishop black has
too much material here so that's one way
to go about it Bishop captures and G 2
but Terris idea is a much more similar
to the one Lasker head against bower
Bishop captures in HD which is much more
of a human approach as you force matters
it's already check what White's it
doesn't have all that many options to
ignore you if you go King h1 then just
Queen h4 is winning so you have to
capture it we have captures Queen to h4
check King that you want and now Bishop
captures on g2 and again if you capture
it's the same plan Queen g4 check King H
1 and now route d5 the rook is coming to
h5 will be checkmate or white must
suffer severe material loss with Queen
captures on c5 but also black is just
winning here so after Bishop captures ng
2 we have f3 trying to either meet Queen
to h1 with King to f2 but also just
making some room for the king
rook F to e 8 blocking of cutting of the
King from the e-file a very important
move and now if you try something like
rook f2 if you want to save the rock
which one is checkmate right away
so here names which trade Knight to e4
which makes sense you want to block the
rooks control of the e-file and now if
the Queen moves perhaps you could escape
and you know seek refuge with your King
on the Queen side Queen to h1 check
white is on the run King to f2 and now
comes Bishop captures on f1 an excellent
in-between move because now you cannot
capture here if you capture
Queen h2 just wins the White Queen the
White Queen is no longer defended King
III just capture and win the game so
after Bishop captures on f1 we have d5
just you know opening up the lights go
at the dark square Bishop nemzer which
also has plans of maybe Queen c3 and
attacking the black ink so f5 now here
if you move the knight let's say
even if you're gonna have six check
which which seems like a great
opportunity king of seven night captures
just rook captures and there's no
defense Queen to g2 will be checkmate
the rook once again controls the entire
efile and once again you cannot capture
because check because the Queen h2 will
be checkmate now you don't even have to
win the Queen as the rook still controls
all of the important files squares on
the along the file and Queen of course
controls these so it would be checkmate
so after f5 we have Queen to c3 now
nimzowitsch uses this opportunity to
threaten checkmate but it is far too
late here pause the video and try to
find it it's a forcing sequence Black
has a fourth checkmate in five I'll give
you a couple of seconds interestingly
tariff played a different sequence of
moves but you can find either one you
know just it's just very nice for those
of you that were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
arrow names which and your game one
second brilliant surprise and for those
you who just want to enjoy the show
Queen G to check I know it's not very
fancy when you start the sequence with a
check but you know it is as it is King
to e3 and now the move you had to find
rook captures on e4 with check the King
has nowhere to go you do have to capture
the rook but you have to capture with
the pawn and now the shortest the
sequence is Queen to g3 check if you
found this congratulations this is the
shortest line this is not what tarush
played after King d2 now you just got
Queen F to check Kingdom one and now of
course Queen e2 will be checkmate for
some reason Tyrus played are much more
well aesthetically pleasing checkmate F
for bringing the King deeper into the
position King captures and now rook to a
faith check King e5 now comes the Queen
to h2 check the pawn is coming the d4
square so the King has to go further up
the board kink the e6 and now rook to e8
check we have King to d7 and here of
course it's making one Bishop to b5
checkmate now it's it's a much nicer
made perhaps tarush decided to do it for
the crowd you know to get a name is ace
king all the way on these seven as this
is you know
much more embarrassing having your king
on d7 so who knows maybe he was already
you know writing the book about this
famous tournament so he wanted to
include such a masterpiece in his in his
book which still hasn't arrived but I'm
sure it will very soon but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it the
second bonus video from the 1914
tournament or some feature book the
tournament the game that won the 2nd
brilliant surprise if you haven't seen
it the game is won the first brilliant
surprise if you're new to the series or
to the channel is capablanca versus
bernstein it will be the first link in
the description below to check it out
in the quite insane game you know if
this game won the 2nd brilliant surprise
you can only imagine what you gain one
the first brilliant surprise but I am
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you are enjoying the capablanca
saga so far some of you mentioned in the
comments that oh no is the conquer saga
over well no it's not this is just the
end of the 1914 tournament of son Peter
Berg now I'm still gonna decide where to
go from here
I don't think we'll go immediately to
the match with Lasker I'm sure we're
gonna cover a bit more games maybe even
another tournament but you know who
we'll see we'll see what happens the
World Team Championship is going on
right now so we might be covering a bit
of that as well
you know we'll just we'll just have to
see what happens well yeah I would like
to thank young JobLink Juan Alejandro
there Mira wear a crystal Schweitzer
Paul Staples and Johan Aleph firkin
revision to my channel thank you a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here think
all for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content had to give you a bit of time
yesterday you know without any videos to
catch up on the whole couple Blanca saga
Robert yeah thank you and I will see you
soon